[Music]
welcome to the sky news daily podcast
with me
dermot mourner and thanks for joining us
as we examine
the story beyond the headline well now
as the health secretary put it for many
of us
2020 has been a year to forget but
before we
consign it to the archives of history
let's take a look at the good
the bad and the remarkable moments we've
witnessed
they're fighting a war here and they're
losing
a tsunami it's a recurring theme now
everyone dies alone you've got masks
gloves
overalls they've just been left there
can you level with ours how many people
do you think will actually die
you must stay at home they're going to
do everything they can to save him but
the odds are stacked against him
i don't want to be a sister to this dude
here you are
it takes you down boris johnson has
tonight been admitted to
hospital i just got better and he didn't
this used to be a theater now it's just
a store room
we're having to struggle to get this
equipment in place it's appalling really
i wonder if you will take this
opportunity to apologize
a first for british muslims ten burials
one straight after another it's the
biggest
day that we've had in terms of falls
since 1987.
i'll go get out i'll go get some fresh
air i can't take this anymore i can't go
on
i'm sick and tired of this when is this
going to stop they ruined
my results this is not what i deserve
you can see him just there
running across the downing streets and
out the back gate
how is it help biblical
it just brings a little bit of joy to a
lot of people at a time when
that's exactly what they need you really
want to give people a hug every night
this is a day to remember frankly in a
year to forget
it's all for prison that's right
hopefully it'll help other people come
along
and do as i did
2020 what can we say what a year with me
to reflect on the challenges humanity
has faced i'm joined by
our science correspondent thomas moore
and ashley's joshie skies
health correspondent good to see you
guys and uh
i mean your feet haven't touched the
ground this year have they and i i'd
like to actually start this
um as a colleague and indeed as a viewer
and listener to
thank you both for how you talked us
through
this crisis you know your cogent clear
and and i think really important
your calm analysis throughout what has
been and is going to be an extraordinary
few months right praise over that's the
last thing
um that's enough of that um let's just
let's just rewind
and thomas i remember when this all
started i mean it seems
a million years ago you were in the
antarctic yeah so i was on a boat with a
british antarctic survey and we got a
news sheet
every day sent by satellite and i could
see early january this this short
one paragraph mentioned of a virus and
as as the days went by
that news story got bigger and bigger
and closer to the front and when i got
off in the falcons
in early february it dominated the front
page i knew what i was walking back into
and so it has proved to be the most
awful year what about you actually
haven't you just started in
in this post on this specialist yeah i
had i'd just been asked to take over
the the health brief and i think october
then i was off in november i was sick
myself
in hospital came back just
in the middle of january and i was told
you know i'd have a nice
quiet monday to friday nine to five
brief and i remember the first day i
walked back in
this unknown virus from wuhan in china
19 hours later i left the office
and here we are well let's remind
ourselves of perhaps the journey
that led us to arguably the greatest
scientific achievements
of this pandemic all the time we've been
waiting and hoping
for the day when the searchlights of
science
would pick out our invisible enemy and
give us
the power to stop that enemy from
making us ill and now the scientists
have done it this is a day to remember
frankly in a year to forget we can see
the way out of this but we're not there
yet so let's keep our resolve
keep doing our bit to keep people safe
until science
can make us free hopefully it'll help
other people come along they
do as i did you know try and
try and do the best for to get rid of
this terrible thing
let's look now at the vaccines
thomas it's it's almost impossible to
believe that we haven't heard or that
most of us haven't heard of
coronavirus kova 19 a year ago ye here
we are
with several vaccines approved on the
cusp of approval and many many more
coming down the line how has science
managed it
so they responded extremely quickly so
when the chinese released the genetic
code for
this new virus they lept on it within
two days they'd
isolated the bit of the genetic
information those
instructions for the spike protein they
all decided this was what they were
going to aim for
because that's what latches on to human
cells that's how it starts off the
infection
makes sense to target the vaccine at
that and that's what they did
robin shattuck at imperial college one
of those developing a vaccine
within two days he had something
sketched out on the back of an envelope
within two weeks it actually assembled a
working vaccine
but it then takes time to see that
through clinical trials just to prove
that it's safe and effective
yeah but actually i mean still so many
questions about the vaccines yes they've
been through the clinical trials and
we've got these
95 efficacy rates if i can say that
correctly but you know it's further down
the line isn't there and because the
coronavirus has only been around for
nine months or a year or so we just
don't know how long they last and things
like that
these trials will continue alongside
the the roll out behind the scenes
you'll still have scientists working and
reworking
every iteration of the vaccine they're
working on to make sure
that it is as effective as they think it
should be and the fact that we've got to
this stage
right now at the beginning of the
rollout where we have some vaccines
with a 95 percent efficacy now that's a
pretty good place
to start there will be and what will
happen is they'll share this expertise
with with other developers
they'll be learning they'll be sharing
they'll be swapping so as we progress
further down the line
in the next few weeks and months and
into next year
these vaccines will only get better but
isn't part of the excitement
of all this i mean some something really
remarkable
might emerge not just dealing with
coronavirus which you know let's be
honest
isn't the most deadly of diseases to
entire populations
that this might be applied to something
like malaria or something like that i
think you're absolutely right
this has opened up a new chapter in
medicine these new genetically
based vaccines have been developed
extremely quickly
and they also seem to be breaking the
old rule of medicine that
older people tend to respond less well
to vaccines
they are responding just as well to
these new rna
and uh vaccines that have been developed
by by three companies now and there is
there are more coming
uh on behind and that's really exciting
what is it they say necessity being the
mother of
invention and all that so okay uh
let's not forget the impact kovid has
had on all our lives and the
devastating consequences for some much
more than others
it's a hell of a it's not been nice
it's a hard road and it's it's a slow
recovery
it's so evil this thing it doesn't care
who you are
it takes you down and it really you
struggle to beat it
i didn't care where i lived your date as
a matter of fact
i expected to die and i thought it would
be a good thing
i'm afraid to go that he'll take me
i don't want him to take me now when she
left this house going into a coma
um that was that was the realization of
how serious it was
and i was nervous that once she'd left
this house she wouldn't come back
and that's ultimately what happened
i couldn't even be there to hold my
mom's hand you know i mean and that's
something that will
just burst me for the rest of my life
well
that is the human cost
and i think we should all reflect first
of all shouldn't we ask
on the the numbers here 65 000 people in
the united kingdom have died with
coronavirus and
counting and indeed that might not be a
fully accurate figure
it's such a desperately lonely
heartbreaking disease you
literally are next to somebody one
minute and they go off and they see
their loved ones being wheeled off into
ambulances
and that's it that's the only contact
they will have had
with their loved ones i spoke to doctor
after doctor
nurses all the healthcare workers and
they said that they are used to seeing
people die that's what they do this is
their job
sick people coming to hospitals the one
thing they couldn't deal with
was the fact that loved ones were
separated at the time of death and it
was brutal for the people who had to go
through them
thomason i mean it's not just about
kobe 19 coronavirus and the response to
it and in particular the
necessary nhs response to it it it's had
so many knock-on effects many of them we
won't be aware of for many years at the
time of recording i hear today you know
just about the
the number of of cancer scans that have
to have been
forgone because the nhs can't deal with
everything at the same time
there are going to be several um
long-term
issues that come from this one of course
the the economic ones which we can't
ignore because that has health
consequences in itself long-term
unemployment but yes the other
conditions uh that
the many people who will have died of
from stroke and heart attacks and cancer
who would have survived in
normal circumstances but haven't got the
care they needed
early on simply because the nhs has been
focused on
on trying to save those those with covid
and i think that's going to be a big
issue and then of course we've got long
covert itself this emerging
uh chronic after effect of of the the
disease itself where the virus seems to
just wreck
the organs and that comes back and
haunts us many years later but away from
that as well we've got
the mental health impacts i mean how
we're going to quantify those
we are only even now scraping
the surface as far as the the mental
health impacts
on people who have had covid who have
who have known people have had covert it
just it goes on and on and i think we're
not going to know about that for
months if not years the mental health
impact is going to be
huge and thomas just expand on
on long covert again this could go on
for well
i mean it could be a condition that you
know eternally affects people it could
alter their lives yeah
i mean there was some research the other
day which showed that the virus is
causing
uh an increased risk of of heart attack
of dialysis a kidney failure
of diabetes and so on it gets into the
organs it
the ac2 inhibitor receptor rather which
is on the cells
uh in the lung are also found elsewhere
in the body and that's how it's getting
into these cells and causing these
long-term problems
one of the people who we heard from in
the clip there tom
i went back to see him three weeks after
i interviewed him in an icu
he answered the door in a wheelchair and
he says he still has
blood clots his lungs are messed up he
can't walk he's out of breath
he can't perform ordinary everyday tasks
he's in his 50s
yeah it's the young as well as the old i
think that's the shocking thing i think
it's really working up a lot of people
to the consequences of having this virus
even if you don't see yourself at risk
of death you are at risk of long covert
so a year on what more do we know about
covid19
we don't know the source of the outbreak
we don't know what
its natural reservoir is and we don't
properly understand
its transmissibility or severity
to defeat this outbreak we need answers
to all those questions
the scientific advice is clear acting
too early creates its own risks so we
will do what is right
to keep people safe guided by the
science will act at the right time
and will be clear and open about our
actions and the reasons for them
on one side we could cause enormous
unnecessary economic and social damage
people being isolated
all the unemployment all the things we
read about in the newspapers rightly
and steer too far the other way and we
end up with the epidemic coming back
and a second spike walking that path is
extraordinarily difficult
so let's talk about the science
thomas i wanted to start with that you
know we've heard that phrase
so many hundreds of times at least
guided by the science but if you've
you've been telling me on the daily
podcast on air on sky news
you know science is not an absolute it's
not written in tablets of stone
it has to be tested all the time and we
have learned so much during the course
of this pandemic about covid19
yes and i think scientists have been too
and that's the point is this was a new
emerging virus had never been seen in
europe before and people really didn't
understand it at all
not just on what it was capable of but
on how how we should deal with it
and so there was no one science uh there
were
lots of scientists with different
opinions on the way
forward and the
there was an evolution in the
understanding so at first the feeling
was that masks may actually
increase transmission because you're
touching you're taking your masks off
and
there's no good evidence in the early
stages that they would work now i think
there's
much better evidence that they do on
balance of everything
so i think that's that's just an example
of how
really scientists too have been learning
about this virus and they would still
say they don't need
they don't know everything they need to
and actually
in terms of who it badly affects we
learned pretty quickly
about the elderly um about ethnicity
very interesting there some of the some
of the work that you've been doing on
that
obesity having underlying conditions
like diabetes we've not so much in those
areas yeah
but it had to be learned the hard way i
mean that was done
uh these weren't people who were
identified
as you know before the pandemic started
killing people they were identified when
the modeling and the data was collected
and that's when they looked at the
figures and thought
oh okay this is this is affecting people
in this cohort this is affecting people
with this co-morbidity
and that's when you had probably that's
why the government
were criticized for not acting
decisively
right at the beginning not to protect
the care homes not to protect
the vulnerable not to protect those
people with underlying health conditions
these were things which were having to
be learned literally on the job and and
that's why there was so much early
criticism
and thomas i suppose other things we've
learned during the goals or the
scientists and the medical professionals
have learned during the course
of the pandemic is you know we've talked
about vaccines but
treatments as well for people who've
who've got kobit 19 badly only do
prophylactics um
you know vitamin d and and things like
that that people have been discussing
and what we always did know the role
of hygiene the hands-faced space yeah
it's all about social distancing if you
if you create an
air gap between people then then they
can't transmit the virus so well and
that's
still the number one way of dealing with
this in terms of public health
in hospitals there have been great steps
forward the recovery trial
that the nhs has been running has been
world-leading
and they were the ones who showed that
for example dexamethasone the steroid
can have a massive impact on death
reducing the
the risk of death in the sickest
patients by a third or so and that i
mean if we hadn't had dexamethasone the
second wave
would have been a lot worse than it
really has been well one thing i mean
just to throw to both of you ashley's
coming on first is you know in terms of
what we
we haven't learned as societies is how
to respond
yes you know the medical treatments the
vaccines the
the actions the the personal actions but
you know if you look at particularly
this second wave in the and the third
wave it's
that some of the countries that seem to
be doing quite well early on are
being affected just as badly as those
that took a different approach there is
no
there is no one size fits no definitely
not i mean
thomas went to sweden uh early on and
that was held up
as a model you know everyone looked at
the swedish model
let's do it the swedish way let's not
have a full lockdown look what's
happening there now so
no i i don't think any one country
everywhere the virus has
rebounded yeah i think asia has done
really well because they had seen
sars and mers they knew how to deal with
these virus and it did come back to
testing and tracing
isolating people who had the virus
who've been infected
and that is the best way of dealing it
in the absence of a vaccine that they
took
the coronavirus much more seriously than
any european country did
they just comprehend that that it could
cause a problem over here the assumption
had always been in europe that it would
be
flu that caused the next pandemic and
also because in those societies you have
societal
compliance they knew exactly when this
virus is spreading
this is how you deal with it you put on
a face mask and you quarantine
and over here it was like look this is a
disease in the far east
we don't have pandemics like that over
here we have high standards of hygiene
look at what's happening yeah you just
wouldn't have believed that you would
close down whole economies in in the
western world i mean you can kind of
believe it maybe in china
but in a democracy no people wouldn't
have believed it and yet we've done it
twice now
well listen it's not all been doom and
gloom the pandemic has brought out some
of the best
in humanity uh here are just a few
examples
doctors coming out of the hospital
clapping to one another
that was yeah what moved me most but
just seeing pictures of people
out of windows and then all like in high
rises and you hear all that sound and
you basically just hear that emotion
coming through that this and
yeah that moves me a lot
we've never had anything quite like this
before we've we've suffered with
wars but this is such it it's a global
thing
and as we've said before it's invisible
we will get through
that i think we've got everybody got to
remember
we will go through eventually
we should take comfort that while we may
have more still to endure
better days will return we will be with
our friends again
we will be with our families again we
will meet
again well prescient words there from
her majesty that was back in april uh
saying that her better times will come
but she certainly knew we
would have more to endure from that and
probably more to come now but those
uplifting moments i mean
you know i mean we've got to start with
i guess the clap for carers and
maybe sir tom was going to call him
captain tom
sir tom i mean standout moments
inspirational i mean that's
exactly what you need in in a time of
crisis you need somebody like
tom say do you know what i've been
through a lot
and i'm sure that if we all come
together support each other
we are going to come through the skin
and the way people rallied
not just to his cause but to other
common causes
you know people working in their
communities leaving food bags on the
doorsteps of those
vulnerable people who were shielding
incredible
incredible selfless acts here's the big
question i think it'll last though this
sense of community that's what
you know people want but you tend to
revert back to what it was don't you
look i applaud those people who have
gone off and found themselves doing this
pandemic sometimes because they've had
to they've lost their jobs and they've
gone and
reinvented themselves and stepped off
the rat race and found something that
they really love to do not necessarily
for for money but because
it's something they really do enjoy and
i hope that that survives
we've seen recruitment figures for
nurses doctors scientists
all of those going through the roof now
so
if there has been something good to come
out of all of this
is our respect and and look you know
science is sexy now
all right people want to be scientists
thomas is sexy now
imagine that but there are there are
children now
who understand you know what an
impact being a nurse or a doctor or a
care worker
or a scientist can have thomas i mean
does it make you look at things
differently look at your family
differently you look at you know
the fresh air differently you look at a
restaurant when it opens differently
i value everything that we've lost in
the last last few months
you know i haven't hugged my parents
since february and um that hurts because
they're you know getting on
my daughter has been messed up she's one
of the a-level people who
had a difficult time back in the spring
and now having a difficult time going to
university so i've seen it up close
these things have mental
health consequences on on everybody and
and that will take a time to heal
and that is the point isn't it now she's
that it's touched absolutely everybody
this has been a pandemic which has
reached into
every single part of our lives there is
nothing which has been left untouched
and you know
yes you can look back on the year and i
look back and say it's been terrible for
so many people but i
i can actually look forward to say i
will look at the world
with a new sense of wonder and awe
because i will realize that there are
people
there who can try and make sense of all
of this for us
ashish thomas thank you both very very
much
indeed now back to work and that's it
until next time head to sky news for the
latest on the covet fight fightback